bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj siano tratti su
raft con ciccio pietro abbiamo fatto
altre robe rispetto al primo episodio
che abbiamo ampliato perché ve lo dico a
fa se dovete guardare video insieme
pescate come la madonna vi prego
tranquillo ci sono io che ami sampei
preso bot
ho comprato da me lo avete visto anche
voi rai con una visione
raga ho visto una luce tipo sembrava
zeus non so se era una luce di un di
vedetta qualcosa premi avvicinerete
andiamo però io ho fame cribbio dovete
cucinare una pietra morto masturzo stop
e scambio che lo dico perché la caccia
un'isola enorme sinistra volte dove che
li hai messi non li sto trovando però
messico per terra o cose prese ratio
pietro no no no di giorno per terra
imparate dai tempi dei bulli office
toscano a scomparire da un nulla
no no no niente tranquillo ma il
seicento momento ciccio ok
vai tra quelli effettivamente non è che
puoi salire in modo etico bravo non
esattamente più di qualcuno mi deve
mettere il cibo sta schiattando fi 48
equiparando e se in passato
poi ognuno di comando ok gli assegniamo
s'ha da fare a meno che non riesca a
farla più alta raga parla straparla roba
incredibile tienila la rotta della vela
un attimo in modo che non accettano
torniamo troppo però dobbiamo
allontanarci se no se non ci schiodiamo
ok diavolo si fa a fare un'altra scala
li morta come faccio a fare un ripiano
alzato ci deve essere quello di studi
abbandonare tipo pilastro in legno
arcavacata dei rottami in un rottame no
un rottame lanciate melo
lo vedete intorno alle scale ho fatto la
scala ancora più alta per raggiungere
l'isola
intorno alle scale dovete costruire
qualcosa perché si arriva allo squalo e
distrugge a scalare distrugge entrambe
poté fare la protezione e le scale a
costruire il calo di come sta
avvicinando i barili prendiamo i barili
per mano io nessuno appaga gli allora
niente via vieni qua no ci siamo ci
andiamo noi non ci arriviamo noi abbiamo
la pagani non abbiamo niente al
selettore piccolo adesso io metto dei
contenitori non è vero mi sono tattica
li mortacci mia è una sauna o c'è pietro
ma è solo estetica o qualche danno ma
non so se così tanto lo squalo padana
fiera è finito amori di mortacci bravo
cosa hai fatto bravissimo mettici
d'acqua dolce innaffia si sono un
giardiniere di mare ok allora cosa vi
faccio abbia fatto dei contenitori
qui potete la roba in più tutto quello
che trovate non vi serve lo mettete qua
così la gente quando ho bisogno qualcosa
ce la metto sotto le scale non abbiamo
da una parte né dall'altra
siamo qui oggi a barile bravo bravissimo
visto bravo bravo eccolo number one
c'era di tutto vari amiche incredibile
lucky la pia cotta cos'è una tilapia
opera un manga che bono ragazzi quanto
ferreri a mettere la foto
sì esatto mib mettiamo la scusa di
ciccio marra che sta crescendo roba
tutta acqua dolce
anche sui così che cresce la roba eh sì
nascono bevendo mette d'acqua come
perché torniamo indietro che quanto
l'annuncio in aula non poi però indietro
non c'è o che cosa c a destra vedo
qualcosa adesso restano molla porca eva
equa i boss l'aido da meno a pagare con
una pagaia non sono roba incredibile
ufficio a testa rinvenuto nell orchestra
ma ti uccido la famiglia accusa mangiato
è morto è morto
basta ad adottare aspetta è morto no si
trasmettano poi lo puoi prendere puoi
prendere le cose che mi sa benissimo se
lo bacchettate di dati diretti dei pezzi
da per bacchettare ok a posto ma si
abbia perso l'andata era molto abbiamo
sulle visioni 5 vedi che c'è qualcosa
c'è una zattera fai tu pietro stavolta
voglio fare anch'io sopra e basta
altrove la prendi roba no no
no siamo qui siamo in questa cieca
vabbè ma è a posto adesso ci guarda come
corre nell'acqua usain bolt aggrappa di
questa cosa ci ha in mano un pezzo di
squadra
ma cosa hai la testa mosca guardano come
si destreggia andiamo verso gli oggetti
sta mancando la allora assi qualcuno
cena adesso prendiamo ste robe cuciamo e
cuciniamo perché siamo messi male
la base musicale 3 2 1
la chicca di qua chi è arrivato di palma
con la palma olio di palma come la pasta
che è stato è stato stupendo ragazzo
possa salire a secco io questa nostra
casa vacca bravo racconto continua devi
raccogliere faccio io vi aspetta sto
raccogliendo su scala nazionale lascia o
trovato questo salito in cima in cima ho
trovato una cassa ma dopo mantova aveva
una cassa incredibile quelle se le casse
sull'isola hanno un sacco di roba
proprio un botto di roba non
allontanatevi dall'isola non domandatemi
latina ma anche se a partire dalla madre
ok arrivo ci sono per quanto nonno preso
allora preso bolt un sacco di roba
la prima cosa che facciamo e sono gli
altri due letti guarda dormiamo tutti
insieme in una famiglia bella ma questo
non è che continui prima o poi si potrà
mangiare oltre che sono tutte le cose
che leggo anch'io continua piantarle
prendiamo letto qui maniera va
prega o che era pronto nel caso raccolto
è sempre divertente ma la chiama che ho
fatto anche allora il cascatore
totalmente in europa sono i retini
raccolgono la roba staticamente ogni
tanto vedete roba dentro se tutti a
dormire
ora carini aspetta che c'è della roba
arriva giorno di arrivo
bari era adesso sdraia di malizia cosa
no che bello dormire vicino a voi
ciao amici che questo ha bisogno di
pisciare di notte leo piantava delle
bombe che riuscissimo a farla diventare
un quadrato friend è bello bravo brown
cazzo no l'orgasmo mela interrotto tra
il legno successo bravo bravo bravo
guardano guarda guarda lo guarda lì che
uomo che si merita la vita su questa
scuotere il ritiro senza saperlo regala
qua perché sei uno stupido che noi serve
totti fidati ma quando la verità tipo
facciamo un buco qua i retini non so se
lo prevede ma non serve fare gli eretini
tutti appiccicati di fi distanti no
carica c'è molta roba mi dicono che è
bene abbiamo trovato un modo per
lasciarti libia a pagaiare pagaie la
parte da rifare di ciccio e uomo
aveva fatto tanto è finora mi chiama
aveva fatto quasi piano di sopra tra
l'altro e adesso si è appena rientrato
nella scia giusta di oggetti però così
ammesso abbiamo tre griglie di cose
bellissime siamo un po che ci ammazzano
e dalle serate inizia la costruzione
seria quindi possiamo fare lì le cose
l'antenna per farci salvare insomma cosa
fede quindi ragazzi questo è quanto per
l'episodio di raft di questa settimana
spero vi sia piaciuto ragazzi il video
ma se tu lo sai perché rischiate
concilia
[Musica]